>> JEFF: Hi. My name is Jeff. I'm an Android
engineer working on applications. I want to
tell you about my favorite features of the
Android phone. My first favorite feature is
the favored types of contacts. It shows you
at the top of your contacts that are starred
and then below, the ones you frequently contacted.
Then if you go to the contacts tab and you
want to find someone, say Will, you can just
type on the keyboard and it will filter down
and show you that person. Another neat thing
about the contacts tab is you can change the
group that you're displaying. So if you have
a group setup in Gmail, you can go here, you
can select the group, and it will only show
you people who are in that group. Another
feature I really like is if you press the
green button twice, it calls back the last
person you talked to.